okay so what we're gonna talk about now
is hydraulic acid - okay acid is one of
the it's an acid it actually it's pretty
present in your tummy
I hope I'm the biologist is going to
tell me I'm pointing to the wrong place
for a tummy but it's in your tummy and
it helps helps digest pops are just food
hydrochloric acid is also a very very
important industrial acid so it'll be
used in lots of industrial processes and
we also use it in the lab for various
things
unlike most of the chemicals I talked
about I can be absolutely sure that
every person watching has a sample of
hydrochloric acid with them as they
watch because hydrochloric acid is found
in everybody's stomach and if you
remember back to school when the
reactions of acids was acids reacting
with metals and that should give us a
salt of some sort and hydrogen so we're
gonna hopefully react a metal which is
war it's really heavy which is zinc
metal okay and we're going to react this
with our hydrochloric acid which is sat
there and hopefully get some hydrogen
out of this and hopefully we'll light it
with a mighty splint a new biography has
just been written of the very famous
physicist Paul Dirac one Nobel Prize and
was perhaps one of the greatest geniuses
of the 20th century and apparently
according to this biography he suffered
from very bad indigestion particularly
towards the end of his life and it was
solved by a doctor suggesting to him
that he should drink orange juice with
some hydrochloric acid in it not very
strong because it would have burnt his
but when he drank this apparently his
digestion calmed down
and he was much happier now fortunately
for most of us we don't need to drink
acid and most people have too much acid
and so when they get indigestion they
swallow a mild alkali magnesium oxide
something like that to calm down the
acidity
here we go get out McDonald's
cheeseburger
okay so we're gonna leave her burger to
digest for a while in the acid
hydrochloric acid was HCl is actually a
gas it has a boiling point which is much
lower than hydrogen fluoride this is
quite surprising to chemists because
usually molecules that are heavier
chlorine is heavier than fluorine boil
at lower temperatures but HF hydrogen
fluoride has strong bonds between one
fluorine another through the hydrogen
so-called hydrogen bonding and HCl
dabangg 8 the hydrogen bonding is weaker
so it has a lower boiling point
this is Grahame my Mike my glamorous
assistant and I think he's gonna hold
some stuff so I think I need more than
one hand for this so okay so this is
concentrated hydrochloric acid so you
could probably see is it fuming now it
does fume a little bit and this is why
again we're using a fume cover today
because you don't want to be in
hydrochloric acid fumes they're not very
good for your lungs and they make your
cough anyway as well so hopefully we'll
pour a lot but in without getting it
everywhere
do we think that's enough probably gates
we've got a spatula with a bit of zinc
metal in it and we're going to put it
into the inter hydrochloric acid and
what you'll do is little F of s and
that's because we're getting hydrogen
giving off so the hydrogen gas will be
given off with any luck that's too much
isn't it that'll s too much so it's a
gas but the hydrochloric acid in your
stomach and in bottles in the lab is
actually HCl gas dissolved in water and
the more you dissolve in the water the
stronger the acid and if you have it
really strong then for example when you
mix it with nitric acid you get the so
called aqua reader king of the acids and
you can dissolve gold if you remember
back to school test for hydrogen gas is
a lighted splint and it should pop
because the hydrogen is going to react
with you the oxygen in the air and we're
going to get a little bit of a pop to
justify can use this now today
don't let
okay watch me scream like a girl yep and
it did nothing I don't know I suppose
the mornings it's a three and a half
hours so we're gonna see what happens to
taste the McDonald's cheeseburger after
three and a half hours and concentrated
hydrochloric acid okay
I think it's absolutely this goes baby
HCl was known long before chlorine was
known as an element originally it had a
rather fascinating name it was called
muriatic acid and chemistry is a very
conservative subject and people still
talk about muriatic acid a few minutes
ago I was looking on the internet
there's an article using muriatic acid
for cleaning your masonry so chemists
when they have a name or something like
that they often like to keep it because
it's their old friend and they want to
keep going using that name we're gonna
need a bigger boat in the words in the
words of Bush either
hopefully this will catch it better
that's the plan we did use if we did in
our practice use a big one so so maybe
it's time for the big guns
they're big flasks
well we saw the cheeseburger and that's
all fine and well it being soft tissue
soft flesh and bum but we actually want
to give it a go with something harder
something more substantial so using a
regular well-known auction site emerged
to purchase a skull a goose skull and
we're going to use that and see how
hydrochloric acid reacts with that
you